[Music]
all right thank you for joining us we're
super excited to talk to you today about
how you can accelerate your solution
development in cloud using our GCP
marketplace and we're super thrilled to
have a great customer home depot code
Center with us along with one of our
great partners metallian you may have
already heard of yesterday or throughout
the conference talking about their
solution and the marketplace so I'll be
covering the cloud marketplace part and
I'll invite Ian and Laura to talk you
through what the customer journey and
the partner journey looks like for a
marketplace so how many of you are
already in Google Cloud today great how
many of you are in the process of
migrating to Google cloud okay a few of
you so as you know that the moving the
cloud journey can be quite overwhelming
you've got to migrate your existing
workloads you've got to figure out how
your open source your VMs if you're
doing containers on Prem how all of us
going to work in cloud and how your
commercial solutions those is fees the
third-party relationships you have how
those are going to work in this new
cloud world at the same time you're in
clouds you're learning about all the
great new technologies that GCP has to
offer whether it's bigquery kubernetes
engine cloud ml etc and what you're
trying to do in the process is figure
out how do I string all these together
to deliver my offerings in cloud so
you're trying to put together GCP
products your own custom-built solutions
third-party solutions and new
applications that you might be building
and putting them all in on Google cloud
so at the same time cloud is powerful
GCP lets you you know pay only for what
you're using which is great you get per
second per minute billing for various
services allows you to easily prototype
spin stuff up spin it down if you're
running in a larger organization you can
have different departments dabbling with
different technologies so it really
makes it easy to kind of get quickly up
and running in cloud at the same time
once you've got a workload and you want
to run into production it's also very
easy to scale
and that's the beauty of cloud now while
the cloud platform is quite strong the
reality is there are always gaps and and
this is really where the is ve ecosystem
comes in to fill in those gaps whether
it's adding an additional capability on
top of maybe a Google cloud platform
networking function or actually solving
a specific problem like we learn about
today with Mattila and ETL ISVs are
there to kind of fill in that gaps in
the ecosystem and make sure that you're
successful in your cloud journey and
what we've done with the GCP marketplace
is allow you as users to tap into that
ecosystem of iose fees that we work with
that we partner with we've vet and we
bless to help you discover great
solutions deploy them easily and get a
single bill all right so you have one
single place to go with cloud you can
build your own infrastructure you can
add on is fee goods get a single bill
and be up and running on your cloud
journey so why use used to be
marketplace how many of you are already
marketplace customers today yeah how
many of you we're using marketplace when
we were called launcher ok small fee so
last week we rebranded from GCP or from
GCP launcher to GCM marketplace we've
got a new shiny logo and a bunch of new
capabilities I'll walk you through
really quickly so what is it GCB
marketplace simply put you can think
about it as your Google cloud platform
App Store right all the different things
you want to do with with app stores like
finding goods trying them out see what
solutions work for your problems we
standardized deployments so what that
means is when you find an ISV solution
you can be guaranteed that you're
running their solution using the best
patterns and practices on Google
platform so it's really not a great
reason to kind of roll your own or or do
it yourself anymore ISPs are working
with us Packaging their goods in a
standard way and making it really really
easy to deploy and get up and running
the next is cloud native billing models
you may be used to you know enterprise
agreements where you're locked in for
maybe multiple months or multiple years
as you know with cloud those dynamics
change right we're used to per second
per minute billing
and the same is true with our
marketplace so many of our marketplace
solutions are actually build along those
models where you're just paying for what
you use and not more than you than what
you actually need and you're getting
this all in a single bill so from a
procurement perspective you're able to
try things out ultimately when you
decide to run them in production or
close you get one bill from Google
across all of your third parties and
your infrastructure usage on Google
cloud platform as I mentioned before all
of our solutions in the marketplace are
vetted by Google and what that means is
we have deep relationships both
contractual and otherwise with each of
our vendors and that means when there's
a vulnerability or there is an update
those vendors are obligated to push
updates to the marketplace and what that
means for you as an customer is that you
can be assured that if you're deploying
something for the marketplace you're
getting the latest and greatest and it's
gonna be maintained and these aren't
vendors that are going to disappear on
you you know next year we actually have
a whole suite of technologies behind the
scenes that we use to security scan all
of our solutions we check for the latest
CVEs
so if there's a vulnerability in a core
operating system image that maybe is not
from the vendor itself but the vendors
using that operating system image were
able to detect that work with the
vendors get it patched and upgraded so
really a secure way of running any
software from is fees in the cloud and
and last but certainly not least here is
easy access to support from vendors you
know the marketplaces are great because
it's a self-service model you don't need
to pick up the phone and call a
salesperson but if you do ever need help
we connect you to sale support quite
easily throughout their product as I
mention before we're a growing ecosystem
and marketplace we're now up at 800
solutions from over 150 partners wanna
applause that's fine yeah it's a huge
number we've been growing tremendously
this is a Forex where we were last year
so it's it's a really really tremendous
pace of growth for for Google for for
you all and for a whole ecosystem
you probably recognize a lot of the big
names here we've products across the
board from security networking storage
data analytics I mean you name it and
we're constantly adding more we're also
proud to announce as of last week
support for kubernetes applications the
commercial kubernetes application
specifically in our marketplace we're
actually the only cloud platform
provider public cloud platform provider
today offering commercial kubernetes
applications and we've been partnering
with a great set of companies you see up
here already these are all live today in
the marketplace you can try out and we
have a whole host more coming a couple
quick points how many of you are running
kubernetes engine today Google cloud
great with the solutions we've built on
the marketplace all of these can be
clicked deployed on to a kubernetes
engine cluster so that means you can
come to the user experience and just in
a matter of a couple of minutes you can
get up and running with any of these
solutions you can actually run these
solutions not just in kubernetes engine
you can actually take them and run them
on Prem or in another kubernetes
environment maybe you're running
kubernetes on GCE or or using other
infrastructure you can still use these
solutions and for the commercial
solutions you still get one single bill
from Google so think about that for a
moment you start your journey in cloud
maybe you prototype your offering or
your larger application in cloud using
third party software and you can
actually take that same stack and bring
it into a different environment and for
the commercial kubernetes applications
you still get one unified bill from
Google for your usage across clouds so a
pretty powerful capability something
we're really proud of and actually
really excited to offer you all of our
solutions that are commercial get
metered through Google so you get one
bill from us but more importantly you're
only paying for your usage so in the
virtual machine world you typically pay
for maybe VM hour or four hours in with
our kubernetes commercial solutions you
can actually pay on different dimensions
for example a database vendor might
charge you based on number of gigabytes
stored not the compute instance hours so
a lot of flexibility a lot of these
solutions
billing based on dimensions that matter
more to the application so it gives you
a lot of flexibility for pricing costing
and evaluating these solutions like I
said you can deploy anywhere you still
continue to get that single great bill
from Google you know our partners are
super excited to to kind of trailblazers
here's a quick quote from Aqua security
a large partner of ours just talking
about the opportunity of getting in
front of customers I think the thing I
want you to take away from from this
message is it's not just Google pushing
these solutions with you it's actually
vendors looking at the marketplace and
saying this is the channel by which we
want to transact and this is the channel
by which we want our customers to
consume our goods so really great
cohesive relationship like I said we're
over 800 solutions this year and growing
like crazy no so with that why don't I
quickly turn to the demo and walk you
through some of the interesting points
of the actual marketplace so the first
thing to note is the Google cloud
platform marketplace is a part of the
Google cloud platform console that
you're already using it's really easy to
access it's actually the first menu item
we've done this intentionally because if
a marketplace is going to be your place
for discovering all kinds of products we
want that to be front and center I want
to highlight a few other things we've
done around discovery we you can of
course access the marketplace from from
the menu here but oftentimes you might
be in a particular part of the console
experiencing a problem maybe you're
configuring a network setting in GCP and
you realize that you need an additional
capability that's not currently offered
by the platform one of the things we've
been doing on a platform is saying how
can we make it easier for you as a
customer to discover solutions from ISVs
wherever you may be in the console let
me quickly show you what that looks like
so here I am at my home page in the
cloud console and let's say I were in
that networking section so let's say I
go to network services what you'll see
here is of course I can configure my
load balancing settings and whatnot but
you can also see a call out here
directly to the marketplace and when you
click this you actually give us overlay
tailored solutions that are specific to
that section so in this case our engine
was smart enough to pick up that you
were in the networking area and it's
going to show you networking solutions
that it thinks might be useful for you
and we've done these integrations
throughout the console so you don't have
to go directly to the marketplace all
the time you can actually discover these
solutions from wherever you might be
when I talk you really briefly are take
you through what the marketplace
actually looks like and some of the
behaviors there as I mentioned we have
lots and lots of products and they span
a variety of different kind types so we
have virtual machines container images
public datasets api's and services
kubernetes solutions operating systems
etc but what we also do is we we also
have all of our Google cloud platform
products there and the reason why that's
important is because what we're trying
to do is create a way where you as a
customer if you have a problem you can
come to one place and find a solution
sometimes a solution might come from
Google and many times our solution might
come from is v's but we don't believe in
a world where you have to go to one
place to find Google products and
another place to find others we want to
have one kind of house where you can
find all of these and not just that you
should build to find solutions across
types whether it's a data set a virtual
machine or a container you can be able
to choose what works best for you and so
we have really robust filtering so if
you were interested only and let's say
kubernetes applications you could click
that you can actually see only those
solutions and of course you can filter
down to subcategories and get into you
know for example the database solutions
there the next thing I want to show you
is what we've done with our deployable
product so virtual machines and
kubernetes applications I want to show
you how those work and how you can
quickly deploy those yourselves so
quickly take let's say WordPress kind of
the hello world of cloud as sometimes we
call it so here you here you see the
basic details page you get a good
estimate of how much it cost to run you
can see that it's a really popular
solution there a lot of deployments
recently learn about the solution we
give you a table on the side which is
showing you exactly how much the
Solutions gonna cost you so we have a
standard default configuration all of
our deployable products are built with
smart defaults that we work with the
vendors with and so we you you know that
if you're just click click deploying
you're gonna be in a known good state
and you also get great pricing
understanding just right off of the
screen here and if you've been using
Google cloud platform for some time
you're probably familiar with our
sustained use discounts a lot of the
products you're be using you're probably
gonna be running for you know weeks or
months and so we actually factor in that
pricing right here as well many of our
solutions also offer trials and so I'm
going to show you that really quickly
here and so we're showing Mattila in
later as well but you can see here's
here's a metallian solution offering a
14-day free trial and what that means is
you as a none customer only pay for the
infrastructure costs though the vm's
that are running this product but not
the license fee for that time period
it's really a great way to try out new
products really risk-free and if you
decide you like it you can just continue
running you don't need to shut things
down you don't need to migrate your
environment you just continue what
you're doing and if you decide it's not
for you or you want to try something
else you can just shut it down and you
can you know you won't be charged for
for those license fees so another great
benefit of Google cloud platform
marketplace another is the ability to
try a free test drive so we kind of two
kinds of trial modes one is the trials I
mentioned earlier and another test drive
test drives are a capability that allow
you as a customer to quickly see the
application up and running in a in an
environment often times with a preloaded
tutorial or sample data these typically
run for you know a few days or sometimes
even shorter periods of time they're
really meant to just give you a quick
familiarity with the solution and see if
it's right for you so you can really
start your journey maybe with a test
drive understand what the solutions
about you know talk to your team see ok
maybe this is a good solution for us
then kick up a trial you know for this
case 14 days put your data in try it out
and if it's going to be good for you you
just continue running if not you spin
down so really really flexible model
there and with our commercial
again on the on the pricing table we
show you detail costing so you can see
here you have the usage fee you get a
solution trial credit for those first 14
days we show you again the the basic
instance infrastructure cost as well so
that's covers virtual machines our
kubernetes solutions are very similar
we also offer services I'm going to show
you that next so send grid is a great
email API I'm sure many of you may be
already using today in this case I've
already subscribed to a plan but one
thing you'll take away here is I've
actually subscribed to send grid and I
can actually manage my subscription
right from within the Google cloud
platform marketplace itself so I don't
need to go to send grid site and log in
again I can change my plans right here
so it's really really integrated again
single bill from Google to manage all of
these services oh no quickly jump next
to kubernetes engine and show you what
we've been doing there
so keeping on with this theme of how do
we get applications in context of the
problem that you might be having we've
actually done an integration with
kubernetes engine where you can actually
see kubernetes applications from right
within the console so here i am i click
applications i can deploy from cloud
marketplace again I get a filtered list
I only see kubernetes applications we
have both commercial ones at an open
source and then I can go through any of
these and in deploy you can see the
similar details pages and I can get up
and running so hopefully that gives you
a good good sense of the different kinds
of inventory we have the different
products again you're getting a single
bill from Google really easy to spin up
try things or shut things down as the
case might be we switch back to slides
so another interesting benefit of the
Google cloud platform marketplace is
actually helping you run open source and
we've actually made a pretty substantial
investment over the years in this
program we call Google click to deploy
many of you may be using these packages
already and we've made some recent
improvements I want to quickly talk
through what that looks like the spirit
behind the click to deploy program is
really accelerating your use of open
source in cloud is it really that simple
the way we do that is we take standard
open source products and we package them
and in ways that you would have done
yourself so these are vanilla
applications we we intentionally do
things in a way where you can continue
following blog posts Stack Overflow
tutorials etc we don't tamper the
packages what we do do is make sure that
they're optimized and run well on GC P
so kind of have that trust that if
you're deploying you know Django Ruby or
any of these you're gonna be in a known
good state from from the start vanilla
configuration as I mentioned there they
continue to be community supported and
so you can follow up in any of the
tutorials blogs that you might have out
there or work with any of the vendors
that offer support on top of open source
applications many of these solutions are
actually packaged in a way that you can
actually run them in production really
well
so it's one thing to run a single node
lamp stack but it's another to run you
know a seven-note cluster MongoDB
instance and if you've ever had to
configure something like that you know
that that takes hours sometimes days of
your time and getting it right can be
quite tricky with our program here you
can actually run you know a clustered
[ __ ] for example in under five minutes
so really really easy to get up and
started with open source we offer VM
images we offer base container images
you can use as well so if you're hosting
your own container environment you can
just use those
we have kubernetes applications that
we've added as well so really big
investment from the open source side
from Google for the general GC
marketplace we're also focused on making
sure that it's a great way for you to
accelerate your prototyping so we talked
about some base benefits of you know
deploying in a few clicks we have these
smart pre-configured settings you're
always going to start in a good state
each of our solutions comes with really
robust getting started guides and
tutorials one of the most frustrating
experiences you know we all kind of
relate to is trying something out and
then just being stuck and not knowing
what to do next so that's kind of the
thing with all of our solutions whether
it's from Google or from a third-party
provider really robust tutorials getting
started guides making sure you don't get
stuck again really low risk we talk
about trials you can try solutions out
we have trials ranging from 14 days to
30 days depending on the vendor so
really robust you can actually apply
free trial credits so if you're new to
GCP or evaluating GCP you have that
budget of you know 300 dollars you can
actually use that budget towards any
solution on our marketplace so it could
even be a commercial solution and you
can in addition to that use free trial
solutions while you're on a GCP free
trial that makes sense so really really
low-risk way to try out the platform and
check out new apps so it's great for
open source it's great for prototyping
but it's also really great for
production so I want to talk to you
briefly about how we think about that so
the journey just doesn't stop when
you're prototyping right you want to
have these multi VM cluster
configurations that you can depend on in
production and that's what we've done
whether it's our open source solutions
through the click to deploy program or
whether it's through our vendors you
know clustered applications that you can
actually take to production we also
offer a lot of flexible pricing models
including byl so if you have existing
relationships with a vendor you can tap
into those support integration one of
the key things of going to production is
making sure that the vendor is going to
have your support and all of our
marketplace vendors are contracted to
offer that support that they that they
list on their details page with
kubernetes you actually have written as
one line but it's actually the power of
communities is quite strong here with
kubernetes solutions you can actually
take the commercial application bring it
down open it up customize it and
redeploy it again you still get meters
still get billed to get one single bill
from Google and with the power of
kubernetes you get some of the
additional benefits like Auto healing so
if one particular instance or node goes
down it'll quickly come back up just
because kubernetes has that capability
built for you another big focus for us
is making sure solutions are secure so
we talked about the verification
pipeline that constantly runs to make
sure the latest vulnerabilities are
detected and we work very closely with
our vendors to make sure that the latest
versions are put up on the marketplace
as soon as possible
and in addition to all those another
thing you want to do in production is
make sure that you have a way to tweak
these configurations you're not just
getting stock things from Google and if
you need to break glass you know you
have to start from scratch again so it
talks a little bit about how we do that
on the kubernetes side we also do
something very similar on virtual
machines so all of our virtual machine
solutions are package using deployment
manager how many of you are familiar
with deploy manager today are using it
okay so deployment manager is our kind
of cloud resource configuration language
it's a way it's a declarative
configuration language where you can
write up exactly what you need to run
give it to an engine called deployment
manager and it will bring up that
infrastructure and what what you should
be taking away from this where the
marketplace is that all of our VM
solutions are packaged with deployment
manager so once you deploy you can bring
it down you can open it up you can tweak
things in this case I'm showing you a
MongoDB instance where you can actually
tweak the zone or the number of replicas
or number of arbiters or even the sizes
of the machines and again just from the
command line quickly redeploy that in a
matter of you know maybe a minute or two
and be up and running perhaps in a new
availability zone so really robust great
for CI CD work floats really easy to
deploy and teardown as well just to
summarize we talked about a lot of
different inventory today in our
marketplace and the list keeps growing
which is really exciting so we have
virtual machines you deploy on compute
engine we have base container images
where you can use actually in any
environment these are open source
packages maintained by Google that you
can layer on top of in your applications
we have kubernetes applications both
commercial and open source we offer a
wide variety of api's and services as
well we also have a huge investment in
public datasets so for those of you
using bigquery it's a great way to get
started we have dozens of public
datasets from weather data to geospatial
data therefore to use and as I mentioned
earlier all of the GCP products are
listed in our marketplace you have one
stop shop to find any solution to a
problem on in terms of Management many
of the solutions are self managed to fit
the case of virtual machines
in kubernetes applications and for our
services those are more of a SAS style
so the vendors off when vendors taking
care of the management for you and when
it comes to billing we're a lot of
flexibility here we have free solutions
like our open source ones we have trials
we have test drives most of our
solutions have the integrated billing so
you get one single book from Google many
of the services are billed from the
partner directly and we also offer byl
so really really flexible depending on
your needs what I want to share with you
next is the story of how a customer like
perhaps yourselves actually got in touch
with the Google cloud marketplace and
explored it found a great solution and
are running it in production so I want
to introduce Ian first from a home depot
quote center and in a bit Laura from
metallian I'll hand it over to you
thanks Neil yep I mean I know I'm a
business intelligence architect for
quote Center I've been an IT for about
18 years I've worked in various roles
development engineering architecture and
leadership I've worked in local
government the retail web and financial
services sector quote Center was founded
about 10 years ago when acquired by Home
Depot four years ago our goal is to be
the center of excellence driving
contractor sales which is a six hundred
billion dollar market we want Home Depot
to be the place of choice for
contractors just as it is for consumers
to support that our goal is to migrate
our existing BI environment which
provided repoing and analytic
capabilities the current environment had
scalability issues the code had become a
little bit unwieldy we had we had a
company strategy to move to GCP we
looked at a service architecture first
and sailed on bigquery as a platform
now we try to run our existing tools but
it really wasn't a good fit now our our
team and our current environment were
built around the Microsoft stack so this
was a big culture and technology shift
for us so we needed a new approach so we
got the team in a room and we came up
with some criteria that made sense for
us the cost was definitely a concern we
wanted a tool that would help transition
our skills we wanted something that
would integrate with source control we
had some source system requirements like
Seco Salesforce and elasticsearch we
knew we wanted to transform the Deo and
apply our business rules we wanted a
tool that was scalable we wanted we knew
we needed to schedule jobs and we knew
we wanted monitoring capabilities we
also wanted a tool that was hosted in
Google Cloud another important thing too
for us was that we had a tool that
worked in multiple environments our dev
test QA and production so we did what
any we have about 50 years combined
experience in our team and we devote any
self-respecting IT professional would do
we googled bigquery ETL tools they took
us to the partner page and there are a
lot of offerings in the partner page we
talked to some of them we did some demos
we got some high pressure sales pitches
at work there wasn't optimal another
theme we saw in the often in the partner
page was a lot of the offerings were
actually hosted on AWS which from a
security and performance perspective
wasn't really optimal for us
there were also other solutions outside
of the marketplace but generally they
required you to install manage your own
infrastructure again not optimal so one
of the partners we found was metallian
one of the things we liked was for 99
cents an hour we could just spin the
instance up we didn't need to talk to a
sales rep we didn't need to negotiate a
proof-of-concept so that's what we did
we launched the instance we poked around
it looked like a tool that you know
might meet our needs the interface was
pretty familiar the transformations made
sense to us it was hosted in Google
cloud platform so we reached out to
matil Ian and they worked with us they
gave us an introduction
they helped us as we move forward we
actually went back to the marketplace
and launched a beefier instance to run
our production environment on one of the
things we really like to us we could
make use of the api's and import all our
code and configurations straight from
source so definite benefit there so
where are we now with the combination of
bigquery am Italian our team hangs in
Thiele phil and vitaly have been able a
load saw some model data into bigquery
we've been following engineering
practices probably more commonly seen in
app dev teams
one of our engineers vitaly was able to
automate our deployments between
environments he integrated source
control he integrated alert in with
slack were Korean currently in the
process of building data quality checks
within metallian we're about 80 percent
migrated from our on-prem and home depot
teams outside a quote sent and now
solely use our bigquery implementation
we feel like we're much better
positioned for the analytic demands of a
growing company and we put ourself in a
better position as we move more towards
a streaming architecture and real-time
analytic capabilities
a few takeaways you know bigquery is
fundamentally different from other
platforms we've used so embrace its
strengths one of the things we've done
is working with Home Depot's
implementation of bigquery we've been a
easily able to integrate the work
they've done and use their projects and
datasets rather than recreate in the
same work on our side we've been able to
use cloud launcher or Google marketplace
to go back and launch new instances
asthma Tilian has come back with it come
out with updates and we've been able to
test them to make sure there were no
braking changes in the way we used
material
one of the things taken advantage of the
parameterization in matil Ian were able
to point to a completely blank
environment and deploy all our staging
table views permissions all straight
from source control one final thing as
we look as we started to do things that
weren't out of the box from Italian we
learn to use the Python Python scripting
in the Google API to fill in the gaps
I'd like to hand it over to Laura from
Italian thank you very much here so hi
everyone my name's Laura Malins and I'm
a solution architect here at metallian
and today I'm just going to give you
some of the highlights of what is
available within the matil ioan product
so I'll just switch across to my demo
machine right here we can see the
Mattila and etl page for bigquery on the
GCP platform so available within the
marketplace as anthills showed and here
we've got our 14-day free trial of the
product and this is really popular with
our customers so they can see how the
product will work within their own
environment you can also try out the
test-drive of the product so you can try
the product in a sandbox environment
completely outside of your GCP project
so you can see what the product does and
then when you decide to launch you just
click through on the launched a compute
engine button and it is very very quick
to launch out matil IAM and the really
nice thing we find about launching matil
ian within the marketplace is that
you've got the ability to configure
those resources as you need it so you
can choose how many CPUs you want in
your metallian instance you can also
choose how much round to allocate to
that and then once the instance is
launched and literally spin up in two
minutes
and it'll spin up as a van with in your
own GCP project and now if I jump across
you access that VM via the web browser
and this is Mattila et al for bigquery
and there are two main jobs available
with enmity Liam there's a
transformation job which is used for
transforming all your data within
bigquery and there's an orchestration
job
which is used to bring all that data
down into bigquery so Ian use an
orchestration job to reach out to his
on-premise databases so here's mitosis
MS sequel databases to connect out to
that database and first of all move
everything off the legacy systems but
also you can use it to bring data from
incremental updates from data source
systems as well and metallian one of the
real benefits of material is it connects
to a whole host of different source
systems so on your screen now you can
see an example orchestration job that
we've got and I'll just talk you through
this briefly so we've got four things
happening in parallel here first of all
we're creating some blank staging tables
for a zone and bigquery we're then using
our cloud storage load component to
connect into a flat file which is cut
which is stored in a cloud storage
bucket and it'll copy the contents of
that flat file down into bigquery in
parallel we're checking for an if
condition so we're checking of some data
or it exists within bigquery and then
we're loading some data out from Google
Analytics
we're also loading out some data from
Microsoft sequel server from our
on-premise system and we're connecting
into Salesforce so our Salesforce
instance in the cloud and we're pulling
some accounts and opportunities data
down here and we're saying if that
account loads fails actually that's a
key thing for my whole job I want my
whole job to fail once this is loaded we
can then transform our data as required
with them
and run that transformation job down
that and all of this is very very easy
to configure with material so I can see
a list of components available down here
I can expand out my load unload folder
and here this will give you a flavor of
all of the different data sources that
metallian will connect into so I want to
add a new source in here say HubSpot for
example I just drag it and drop it and
it's a very user-friendly interface it's
all dragging and clicking and dropping
and it presents this visual view of
material so I'll just scroll down and
show you some more of the sources
available here so I think at the last
count we are up to about 60 our data
sources but we're constantly receiving
feedback from customers and we're always
adding to these sources here as well
and then finally we've got this API
query component so for a native source
that for your data that metallian
doesn't have a connector for you can use
this API query component to connect in
and metallian can pull that data from
your API down into bigquery and these
sources are very easy to configure you
can simply click into one of them and
it's just a selection of options so in
Salesforce I can choose my
authentication by say username password
or by OAuth then I pick the
authentication I've already got set up
and now what matil ian does is it will
connect into Salesforce as you as a user
so it takes a few seconds to do that
because it's connecting in through and
what it'll do now is it will present a
list of all of the objects I've got
available for me in Salesforce that I've
sent kated to access so it'll show that
list and it will show all of the custom
objects within Salesforce now so I think
it's taking a couple seconds to load
that because the Wi-Fi is quite slow and
then once you've configured from that
data source you pick down that drop-down
you select which fields you want to
bring through from that source and then
you simply give the name of the new
table that metallian is going to create
for you in bigquery to write that data
through into here now we can see the
list of all those data sources and we
can see that metallian will bring any
custom wand back for us and then once
I've got all the data available within
bigquery I can then transform it so
here's my transformation job I've got
different components because this is all
about working within bigquery and really
harnessing the power of bigquery to
manipulate and transform our data as we
require so then you can feed that data
out into your business intelligence tool
or you can pass it on to your data
scientists as Ian did ok perfect so I'll
just hand back over to Ann Hill for the
last bit
[Applause]
and so just a recap hopefully what
you've taken away today is you can
really accelerate your journey and cloud
and your solutions development using the
GCP marketplace you get that single bill
from Google for your licenses as well as
your infrastructure making it really
really easy to procure and try things
out when we hopefully you've also
understood that we have solutions across
the board whether it's datasets
containers VMs API is etc so really
really broad inventory 800-plus
solutions here's a link cloud to
google.com slash marketplace go give it
a spin check it out for a trial if
you're a partner and you want to
participate and be part of our growing
ecosystem got a link up here or you can
actually get in touch with our sales
team and get you on boarded and last but
not least don't forget to drop in your
feedback in the Google cloud next app
about the session
[Music]
you